phil john congratulations you guys have
landed in the final round of this
competition now we're sending you back
to your home for just to recreate this
iconic weapon from history
the partisan
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
four days
today's day one and the main thing i
want to get accomplished today is
forging out that socket if i don't get
that done that's going to put me behind
where i need to be for tomorrow how do
you think of that why does it sound cold
because the spear is going to go inside
for the blade i'm starting out with a
good chunk of sheet steel 1095 high
carbon there we go i am overcome with
joy with the amount of progress that
i've made today
first thing we got to do is get the
profile established get our medial ridge
ground in take a lot of the weight out
and get it ready for heat treat
a weapon like this is meant to be swung
so it needs to be well balanced it can't
be too top heavy but uh i need to
balance that with strength as well so
the plan for heat treating the blade is
to clay up each blade individually and
differentially harden the edges so that
it stays nice and soft and springy
and only our cutting edge gets hard if
the whole blade was as hard as the edge
it would be really likely to break
that's straight
now we're gonna clay and heat treat the
flanges one at a time
last quench right here
hell yeah
things hard as woodpecker lips
today is day two and the plan for today
is just to get that media ridge situated
just right what i got to figure out
is how exactly to do this smiths have
been making medial ridges for hundreds
if not thousands of years but when all
of my research that i found i could not
find how they traditionally put medial
ridges on blades that were so pronounced
so i'm really happy to go just a little
different route than i think what is
traditionally done
i'm going to take bar stock tack weld it
throw it in the forge forge weld it
throw a bead of weld and then i'm going
to go in and clean up those welds so i
get those really drastic curves
the weight of the piece is going to be
heavier but i'm gonna have structural
integrity that is sufficiently ground i
think we are ready to
heat treat
[Music]
i think we are good
j4 sun's finally out today is mostly
refining work fit and finish
getting everything cleaned up sharpened
and getting the spear mounted
so now i'm forging a nail to affix the
uh spear to the shaft so i've just got a
piece of square stock tapered down we're
going to cut it off of the parent bar
and chuck it up with a nail header
there's our nail
i could do better see how the head's off
center
i don't know this one it's going to be
inside you're not going to know it's
fine oh god i'll know though
i'm going to make another one
that one's better
what my spear brings to the table is the
good blend of form and function
and with the way i made it it should be
pretty much indestructible
feels good
the plan for today is to clean up the
surface grind
get everything nice and shiny then
continue on with the bevels and then
start assembling
just going to kind of do a dry fit and
see where i'm at with the
pole here not going to peen it i still
need to take it all apart for some more
work but just getting that step in the
process
done and ready to move forward with it
whoops
i'm thinking ah it'll come right off no
problem
i was wrong
i was like why am i taking this out if
it fits so well but to keep working on
it i need it out
wow i'm an idiot
that's not budging as i'm prying on this
vise trying to get the bar out it dawns
on me
heat up the metal
burn the wood it'll come right out
[Music]
voila disaster averted
of all the things that go wrong right
a major build ten thousand dollars on
the line he prematurely gets his wooden
staff stuck in it
so i'm not planning on testing right now
if it's gonna malfunction if it's gonna
break at this point i want the judges to
have the honor of destroying something
that i've built not me i think that
feels good
all right bladesmiths this is the kill
test
to test the lethality of your weapon i
will deliver killing blows on this
ballistics dummy
fill you up first you ready for this yes
sir man let's do it
going into this test my heart's starting
to pump a little faster doug's hopefully
just going to destroy this ballistics
dummy and we're gonna have pieces flying
all over the place and blood on the
walls
[Music]
[Music]
all right phil the design you have here
is
scary
that's a very thick spine you have the
edges are sharp as you can see
very deadly
the one thing about this is that
it's heavy
that is something to take into account
when you're carrying something like this
into battle and you gotta move multiple
times but more importantly your weapon
will kill
thank you sir
all right john your turn are you ready
let's do it
i'm feeling good about the kill test i
know my blade is sharp and i think it'll
cut really well
[Music]
[Laughter]
pushed out a rib
all right john i love the feel of the
blade you can really fight with it
because it's lighter your blade also is
very slim that it penetrates in there
and there's no resistance even enough to
push out a rib
more important i love the balance i love
the feel
and it will kill
you sir
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the pike push and armor
stab
now the partisan was often used in
castle or in city defense so to test the
overall strength and construction of
your blades i'll be pushing against
these pikes with the blade and then
stabbing into the armor now this test is
not about what your weapons do to the
targets it's about what those targets
are going to do to your weapons
philip you're up first you ready yes sir
[Music]
all right phil this thing is a beast
the weight the shape of your tip really
makes it a good penetrating weapon the
issue i have as a partisan was a
standoff weapon got to be able to
control it
and at full extension
that weight's hard to control
i like the fact that you have this high
medial ridge i like your design
my only issue is the weight
good job thank you sir
john you ready let's do it
i am a little bit worried about the
blade going into the strength test you
know stabbing at armor with the blade
being as thin as it is i was really
concerned about keeping the weight down
hopefully it holds up
[Music]
[Music]
okay john the weapon is light it's well
balanced i really like that issue i have
is down here it looks as if this is the
thinnest spot now you've got a
differential heat treat you can actually
see those lines and that soft core it
may be what's affecting this blade so as
soon as i stabbed in and it locked up
that blade went
with this bend it's not safe to test
this blade anymore it's going to keep on
bending and it's going to get harder and
harder to control
john your blade has suffered a
significant deformation in the course of
our strength testing it's received a
vote of no confidence from the judges
i have to ask you to please leave the
forge
i completely agree with the judge's
decision with the way that blade bent i
wouldn't be comfortable testing it
either
seriously
even though i'm not a forged and fire
champion i am proud of the work i turned
in bill congratulations brother you did
a great job and i'm happy for you
phillip
you are the new forged and fire champion
that's a title that comes with a check
for ten thousand dollars good job
i just want fortune to fire
john you're an awesome dude an amazing
competitor
the sense of joy and accomplishment
knowing my daughter is going gonna see
there's so many emotions right now i'm
there's i'm overwhelmed i'm trying to
hold back tears man
i'm taking it home to texas
[Music]
you